Di bab ini kita akan membahas kerangka berpikir
tentang lingkungan komputasi
yang bisa diterapkan mulai dari laptop kamu
sampai skala superkomputer
di akhir bab ini
kamu akan paham konsep dasar sumber daya komputer
dan bagaimana hubungan satu sama lain
jadi apa itu sumber daya komputer? simpelnya
itu adalah komponen-komponen yang membentuk sebuah sistem komputer
kita punya CPU atau central processing unit
yang mengeksekusi sebagian besar instruksi, lalu ada memori
atau RAM yang menyimpan data sementara
dan instruksi program
dan kita punya GPU atau graphics processing unit
yang dirancang untuk rendering grafis
tapi bisa juga dipakai untuk komputasi tujuan umum
yang butuh banyak pemrosesan paralel
seperti simulasi saintifik, analitik data, atau machine learning
sumber daya ini bekerja bersama untuk menjalankan program
dan masing-masing punya satuan ukuran tersendiri
misalnya CPU diukur dalam jumlah core
dan clock speed, sementara memori diukur dalam byte
giga, mega, dan terabyte
untuk setiap program kita
kita butuh sekumpulan sumber daya
untuk menjalankannya
penting untuk mempertimbangkan sumber daya yang dibutuhkan
agar eksekusinya efisien — lokasi tempat komponen program dijalankan
dan bandwidth infrastruktur yang menghubungkannya
berperan penting
dalam menentukan performa keseluruhan
misalnya, GPU mungkin lebih cepat untuk menghitung bagian tertentu
dari program kita, tapi kalau memuat program ke memori GPU
butuh waktu lebih lama
mungkin lebih cepat pakai CPU saja. sekarang
mari bicara tentang scaling sumber daya klasik
ada dua pendekatan: vertical scaling
dan horizontal scaling. vertical scaling artinya meningkatkan
kapasitas satu sumber daya
seperti pakai CPU yang lebih bertenaga atau tambah memori
dalam satu node fisik
di mana node adalah satu unit dalam cluster komputasi yang mencakup banyak
sumber daya di dalamnya. horizontal scaling
artinya menambah lebih banyak sumber daya
seperti beberapa CPU atau GPU
yang bekerja bersama dalam satu node atau beberapa node
kedua pendekatan ini punya kelebihan masing-masing
dan kekurangannya, pilihan tergantung pada kebutuhan spesifik
dan persyaratan kasusnya. sekarang mari kenalan dengan jenis sumber daya baru:
sumber daya quantum. sumber daya quantum memproses informasi quantum
dengan quantum processing unit atau QPU. sebuah QPU
adalah keseluruhan sistem yang bertanggung jawab
untuk menerima instruction set quantum yang dapat dieksekusi
atau quantum circuit dan mengembalikan
jawaban yang akurat. artinya
QPU mencakup satu atau lebih chip quantum
misalnya sebuah IBM Quantum
beserta berbagai komponen tambahan lainnya
dalam dilution refrigerator
yang mendinginkan chip quantum tersebut
seperti quantum amplifier, kontrol elektronik
dan komputer klasik yang dibutuhkan
untuk tugas-tugas seperti menyimpan instruksi
dan waveform di memori, mengumpulkan hasil
dan nantinya untuk decoding error correction
secara umum, sumber daya quantum diukur
dari kualitasnya lewat layered fidelity scale
jumlah qubit
dan kecepatannya lewat circuit layer operations per
second atau CLOPS. hari ini kita akan memperlakukan chip quantum
sebagai satuan ukuran, mirip cara sistem manajemen sumber daya
memperlakukan GPU — bukan berdasarkan jumlah core
tapi sebagai satu unit penuh. lalu bagaimana dengan scaling?
seperti sumber daya klasik, scaling sumber daya quantum juga bisa
dikategorikan menjadi vertikal
dan horizontal. vertical scaling
berarti menambah jumlah qubit per chiplet
atau per chip
sedangkan horizontal scaling adalah menghubungkan chip-chip
dengan couplers atau dengan interconnect klasik
dengan definisi itu sudah jelas
mari bicara tentang manajemen sumber daya
manajemen sumber daya dalam infrastruktur komputer mengacu
pada proses perencanaan
alokasi, dan pengendalian penggunaan sumber daya komputasi
seperti CPU, memori, storage
dan bandwidth jaringan untuk memastikan
pemanfaatan sumber daya yang efisien dan efektif
kamu bisa bayangkan manajemen sumber daya
seperti permainan Tetris multidimensi di mana setiap blok
adalah kebutuhan job kamu
dan tiap dimensinya adalah satu unit sumber daya. tugasnya
adalah menyusun blok-blok job itu ke dalam kubus
dari semua sumber daya yang tersedia. manajemen sumber daya
adalah tugas yang cukup rumit dan fasilitas komputasi yang berbeda
menerapkan strategi berbeda untuk mengkonfigurasi infrastruktur mereka
sesuai kebutuhan spesifik pengguna mereka
untuk menerapkan konsep yang baru kita pelajari, kita akan pakai
Slurm. Slurm adalah software open source
untuk manajemen sumber daya
untuk keperluan demo
saya punya setup lokal dengan tiga virtual node
kita bisa lihat informasi tentang node-node komputasi itu
dengan menjalankan perintah scontrol
kita punya dua partisi atau grup node
normal dan quantum. partisi normal terdiri dari node-node
yang hanya punya akses ke sumber daya klasik
dan partisi quantum punya akses ke sumber daya quantum
pertama-tama kita jalankan contoh sederhana
hello world klasik dengan Slurm
pertama kita butuh program hello world itu sendiri.
Dan ini program kita yang cuma mencetak hello
world.
Sekarang kita perlu memberi tahu resource manager
sumber daya apa yang kita butuhkan untuk menjalankan program ini
seperti yang sudah kita bahas, Slurm menyediakan cara untuk menentukan
semua metadata untuk sebuah job lewat
sebuah shell script
dengan anotasi khusus Slurm
anotasi ini memungkinkan kamu menentukan kebutuhan sumber daya
parameter scheduling, dan lain-lain.
Kita bisa cek submission script kita
dan di sini ada spesifikasi partisi
berapa node yang kita butuhkan, berapa task per node yang akan
kita jalankan, berapa CPU per task yang akan kita pakai
dan script mana yang akan dijalankan
dan ini adalah program hello world kita.
Untuk submit job kita ke eksekusi, kita cukup jalankan
satu perintah yaitu sbatch
dan berikan script kita sebagai argumennya
kita bisa cek execution queue
dan lihat program hello world kita sedang berjalan
di partisi normal di node c satu
setelah job selesai, kita bisa cek hasilnya
dengan melihat file output.
Dan itu saja.
Kita juga tertarik untuk menggunakan sumber daya quantum
oleh karena itu mari buat program hello Qiskit yang sederhana.
Ini program Qiskit kita yang mencakup semua
langkah yang diperlukan mulai dari pembuatan circuit
optimasi, eksekusi, dan post processing.
Dan di sini semua konsep pemrograman yang sudah kita bahas
tentang quantum circuit, transpiler
dan Qiskit primitives
sekarang kita perlu membuat submission script
seperti sebelumnya, tapi di sini kita tentukan
kebutuhan sumber daya quantum
karena kita sudah menentukan sumber dayanya
dan partisi di cluster kita
sumber daya quantum apa yang tersedia
Qiskit primitives akan pakai
sumber daya yang dialokasikan untuk menjalankan quantum payments.
Sekarang kita perlu menjalankan program kita.
Dan setelah job selesai, kita bisa cek hasilnya.
Dan ini nilai ekspektasi kita.
Dan itu saja untuk manajemen sumber daya
di bagian berikutnya kita akan membahas
tentang model pemrograman